outlined some reasons why you might
invest in designing constructing and
using a decision support system okay now
by the way that way the best is really
important when you hear the word invest
what do you think of say to you yes
right like two seasons what systems as
with all systems are not free okay
you're putting money what else you have
to put time these things they're just
you know you can't just quit your
fingers and have one and also effort to
make it and then to use these kinds of
systems also it takes effort and money
and time okay so why buy that all right
well I've got arm for reasons for you
not exhaustive but it's sort of just to
start and they've made the general most
important reasons okay so my first one
is that often decisions require
computation computation as in um you
know this thing that a computer does
okay so my example for this when you're
thinking about decisions right we have a
organization the governors of the
organization called was anyone know it
stands for very important today the
bureau all the meteorology right which
is all about weather prediction okay so
they have to make some decisions on what
forecasts they publish and you know what
they should say today and tomorrow and
next week and all that kind of thing
gonna be like next right now these guys
their job we would say his weather
analysis or if you like weather
prediction okay and so in order to
predict the weather it's not easy right
they've got lots and lots of computing
power that goes into or how to do this
pretty twitter does anyone know what
kinds of things do they need to know
what kind of things they try and work
out okay so we say current weather
what does current wear that mean what
does it say what does it mean to say I
know what the weather is right now
because I think knowing what the weather
is is more than tank it's raining or it
raining what other kinds of things
there's been more specific what do you
need to know print okay
so you need to know air pressure you
need to know humidity yeah I think
you're thinking about not meteorology
Pratt acupuncture everything humidity
what else there's an obvious one you
missing is it is it cold temperature
okay
that's usually been named one actually
okay now
not just that I have to know all these
things right but they have to take all
these things and put them into large
equations very complicated equations
that work out when all of these things
interact with each other right and how
do they how they produce weather in a
particular area okay so in other words a
computer has to sift through all this
data and analyze it and do apply all
these algorithms to it it's very very
complex and it's hard for humans to do
okay so when making a decision about
where the prediction we use decision
support systems to help us because this
thing which is hard for humans to do
computers are very very good at right so
we bring them in okay now secondly going
after the same kind of thing right
air pressure humidity temperature okay
where do you need to know or how many
places would you need to know air
pressure humidity and temperature to be
able to accurately gauge what the
weather's gonna be like say in a city
say in Sydney think about that area okay
points places I should point locations
do you think you need to know to do an
accurate yeah yeah that's right
so not just on the on the land right but
you're going to go out to sea because
the sea affects us see if you can lay
all the surrounding areas like in the
mountains all that kind of thing and
what kind of dancing do you think you
need do you think it'll be enough to
have one in one per summer would that be
enough enough pressure points enough
places where you know the temperature
what do you think one per summer was
enough
I I didn't think it's nearly enough I
don't think is nearly enough only where
the stations are everywhere okay and to
be able to know the weather in once I
work you need to know because something
is quite a large geographic space right
so what I'm getting at is that not only
do decisions here require lots of
computation but they just require lots
of data for spot okay just there's just
lots and lots of information to take
into account all right now can you see
why I'm getting it
why this helps us with I'm saying why we
need decision support systems right
computers are really good at handling
lots of data whereas our brains kind of
fizzle out after thinking about a finite
amount of things okay so we need
computers to help us now let me give you
that was whether I was just following on
the previous example let me give you
another one a business example this time
okay so right now at least I think the
room is either Apple is gonna release a
Smart Watch it's the latest room isn't
the moment there prizes for guessing
what it would be cold but anyway what
the tricky things would happen products
right is that they get released globally
right and at least they try to release
them all around the same time okay yeah
let's just try and put this on a scale
of like one to ten if Apple were to
announce on the iWatch today okay on a
scale of one to ten what do you think
the demand would be like one eight kind
of depends on how they sell it right I'm
going to suggest right yeah you it's a
it's a whole new product category right
it's been a lot it's been quite hot as
well and it's a cool for good to say
okay people love Apple some people are
gonna line up for Apple things not
knowing anything about the products it's
just they want to have the next Apple
thing okay now you see how that poses a
problem for Apple right there a global
company on the day that they actually
start selling these things right there's
gonna be all of this demand okay so your
head about
your Tim Cook you're sitting in
Cupertino what kinds of decisions do you
have to make based on the fact that your
process is gonna have a global release
or anything what kinds of decisions yeah
okay number one how many do I make but
you can't sit around waiting for
pre-orders right because by that point
is too late already people are gonna
expect it you know if we if we order on
day one we want it to be ready
like maybe day 30 or something like that
any longer where US consumers get very
angry and we're like where is that
product okay
so that means Tim Cook has to start
building them way way way in advance
especially if he's building like what
kind of scale I'll be talking about
we're talking about like dozens hundreds
how many do you geeks gonna build I
think it's gonna be in the multiple
millions okay you go to look up the
stats of how many iPhones that Apple
sold last quarter it's crazy
okay all right now how many is not the
only question because this is a global
release right so what other questions do
we have to think about okay good
now Cristiano how many and where
interact with each other right because
it's like look suppose we do our arm our
thinking about how many way you'll need
worldwide but then you have to work out
okay do I put 5% here and 10% there and
35% here how do you even make that
choice right
and then just to throw another spanner
in the works right when do you schedule
them to arrive right because I assume as
a supplier you don't want to wait until
some guys say oh where our stock can you
build some more because they'll take way
too long for them to actually get new
stock in to actually keep on getting
sales pumping you're like I don't think
so you're all these different questions
how do you make a decision like that
right upon which billions of dollars
right well the answer is you need to
know a lot you need to be able to
accurately predict on this area they buy
such and such an amount of our products
on a quarterly basis right
these guys sell them these quickly so
that's when I know how quickly I have to
send a new stock okay and I have to know
that about every different location how
many Apple stores are there how many
different cities how many different
countries hard decisions to make right
you need to know a lot to be able to
make an accurate choice okay